I was gonna make a thoughts from places
video from Dublin but then I realized
that you took all of my footage and used
it in your Dublin video so I'm left with
just this clip of a woman smelling her
fit in shame like she is an opponent of
the Swindon Town suitably poopers who by
the way hey cup three games left in
their entire FIFA 11 history and are on
the cusp of winning the Barclays Premier
League link in the doobly-doo so Hank I
was pretty upset with you for borrowing
all of my footage from Dublin but then
something much more important happened I
began to develop a cold sore you can't
really see it but you know you know
you're gonna get one before you get one
yeah I know I'm gonna get one so Hank
why is that such a big deal well on
Thursday I'm going to be in a Google+
hangout with the President of the United
States Barack Obama and I am probably
going to have a cold sore my only hope
of not having a cold sore is this stuff
Abreva which is the only fda-approved
medication for cold sores and literally
costs more than gold wait did you just
say I was gonna be in a Google+ hangout
with the President of the United States
of America oh is the sound that my
anxiety makes I think I have no idea
where this happened but someone at
Google called me a couple days ago and
was like do you want to hang out with
the president and I was like yeah it
depends the president of one because I
just hung out with the president of
dftba records Hank green for like a week
and a half and it was alright but oh you
know I wouldn't do it again and they
were like yeah the President of the
United States Barack Obama do you want
to be in a Google hangout and ask him a
few questions and I was like mm-hmm
okay so anka I'm gonna get to ask the
president some questions I'm gonna
improvise a bit but I have prepared a
few my first question is hot hi mr.
president my name is John Green oh my
god what is air then I also have would
you rather fight ten duck sized horses
or one horse sized duck and of course
mr. president I can't help but notice
that Canada got rid of its one cent coin
and nothing bad happened how do we still
live in a world with pennies and then of
course I have to ask him who the eff is
Hank by the way you can also ask
questions to the president as can anyone
there is a link in the doobly-doo to
submit your questions there is also a
link in the doobly-doo to RSVP to the
hangout or whatever I don't understand
this terminology but basically it'll be
live on YouTube at 4:50 p.m. Eastern
Time on Thursday I will be the one with
the cold sore anyway I'm a dough
actually aware of the fact the President
of the United States doesn't care if I
have a cold sore and also that he will
forget Who I am within like four seconds
of the end of the Google
so that he can go back to like country
running well I am nonetheless extremely
anxious about the cold sore and also
every other facet of this interaction
and I saw a similar phenomenon albeit on
a much different scale when we were on
tour because many people when we met
them were very like nervous and
self-conscious I think we met more than
6000 nerdfighters in 10 days and I can
say with authority that none of them had
anything to be embarrassed about but I
know that many of them still felt
embarrassed anyway I also felt
embarrassed and that's got to be
inherent problem with meeting people you
admire whose work you really like it
will never be normal because you're
always going to be hyper conscious of
everything that could go wrong and if
say you're President to the United
States you had those interactions with
people every single day Hank like most
of your interactions even with your
staff are with people who are like oh my
god that the president everybody be calm
that is the number-one reason why I
would never want to be President the
number 2 reason is that no matter how
sensible your policy ideas people only
want to talk about ideology and the
number 3 reason is that I get cold sores
every winter and if you're president you
can't hide Hank when the Eddie and I
first started dating she told me that
when she was in eighth grade she
realized that everyone else was thinking
about themselves as much as she was
thinking about herself and that
therefore no one else had any time to
think about her this epiphany was one of
the central reasons why Sarah was a
relatively well-adjusted teenager she
realized that when she was like 13 I
realized that when I'm actually still
trying to internalize it
hopefully it'll happen before Thursday
afternoon but regardless Hank I'll see
you on Friday